sir after onion slices and cylindrical
shells we're going to do volumes by
cross-section okay here's why right let
me give you a shape and give you a shape
won't try and draw it as accurately as I
can mm-hmm I'd love you to draw this
well because we're gonna do some
manipulation with this in a second
here's my impression of a sweat pyramid
okay here's the base now think about
this this is quite emphatically not a
solid of revolution so you cannot do it
by any other slices because there's no
way you can cut it up where you'll get
these shapes are and you can't do by
cylindrical shells either but I can cut
this thing up in such a way right so
that I get a whole bunch of definitely
thin slices right they all share very
common characteristics because it's a
square pyramid so which way would I cut
this up to get shapes that are similar
to each other now I think if we cut it
horizontally right at waist according to
the way I've drawn it if I cut it
horizontally then being that I've told
you it's a square pyramid right each one
of the pieces right I can't call it a
slice of angular slice of cut called a
shell because they won't be what will
the pieces be then we'll all be squares
every single one right so we're going to
do a whole bunch of squares and the
smallest one would be up here a square
of width 2 0 I guess so let's try this
in order to do it to actually calculate
this let's say it has a a perpendicular
height of H hi H okay and because it's a
square pyramid I need one other
measurement what do I need the the base
I need its side length oh nice so that's
just for the sake of illustration let's
just call that a 8 units okay I suppose
I want to say that will make it a right
pyramid so it's gonna go straight up
rather than off at an angle but in some
senses that wouldn't matter but let's
just keep with this okay now how am I
gonna do this I want something like this
I want to get toward there
okay so I need to decide which one of
the slices we set horizontally right
isn't that coordinate system here so
let's introduce one where we can take
different values differ give us
different slices okay
so right now I'm gonna look at this side
on okay because this 3d is confusing me
a little bit right here's what I'm going
to do okay now this is a little unusual
but I'm going to look at it from the
angle of not like directly from the side
or directly from the front I'm actually
going to look from the diagonal okay why
would I do that I want you have a think
about why I would do that okay if I
looked at it directly side on okay when
I take those slices what am i
measurements going to be hmm see the
problem is they're not going to go
through my axis right I in a similar way
that I have an axis of rotation here
right I don't have an axis of rotation
here but I do have something that
everything turns around namely the from
the apex down to the base okay now I
want to have that on my diagram okay
it's harder to actually do calculations
from that if I'm looking sidon okay so
therefore I now have this this distance
here which is a trans the perpendicular
height but if I'm looking at a diagonal
this is not a right this this width
across here this is this is this
diagonal here right so it's not a what
is it
what's a square right square base okay
if you look at it from the top okay
you've got a PR and pay here this is a
45-45-90 triangle or alternatively if
you want your Pythagoras right you're
gonna get the square root of two hey all
right cool so now I have a measurement
down here okay now I want to cut this
into pieces right and I also didn't axis
so I'm going to say let's let's put a
piece an arbitrary piece in yeah okay so
this is my cross section this is what
you taught me to do to cut across
horizontally okay and if I were to take
this up and for whatever you'd get a
square the problem okay so there's my
cross section I need an access view so
I'm gonna call this the x-axis right and
this is what's going to vary right this
is how I'm gonna be slicing this guy up
okay so this is X and this is H this is
the screw a okay don't forget this is
constant this is constant this is very
right so number one what about what I
built so far I can say what's the width
of the cross section going to be it's
gonna be Delta X isn't it cuz that time
I'm cutting this thing up right so I
want all of those to be very small okay
now I'm going to add up a whole bunch of
things okay what is the variable that's
going to change again it's going to be X
that piece there one two one two
it remains consistent right so I'm
trying different values of x okay now
we're used to getting boundaries
provided to us like this okay the
boundaries of the volume I'm after are
right here on the diagram but because
this is a coordinate system it's hard to
see them right what would be the
smallest value of x that I can have the
smallest value of x I see be zero
it'll happen right there okay you see up
there it'll be it'll be zero okay what's
the largest value of X
I could take it'll be it'll be H that's
as far as I go right so therefore this
volley oh I'm gonna get is from naught
to H okay now keep going I need some
extra pieces in here I already know what
this one is going to be the width of
each cross-section okay that's going to
be Delta X okay
but now the piece that I'm missing and
this is the part which takes some work
okay is in here right what belongs there
if I've already taken into account vo
how thick each cross-section is right
well that's requite here is the area of
the cross-section in this case it was an
annular slice in this case it ended up
being a rectangle when you unfold it in
this case it will be a square you
identify this at the beginning right
namely it'll be for instance it would be
a square like this there you go there's
one of my cross-sections okay maybe I'll
make this clewd so you can see it's
referring the same thing okay sir I want
to know the area of the cross-section
it's just a square right so what do I
need to know to work out its area I need
to know its side length don't I I need
to know what this is hmm how do I do
that I've got I've got similar triangles
here don't I in fact I have to have some
kind of similar figures in order for the
cross section to have some kind of
consistency because otherwise I've got
nothing that I can put in here that will
be true for all of the different cross
sections okay right so how do I work at
similar triangles it looks to me like
this thing here's the diagonal of the UM
of of this square right it's this so
being that it's a diagonal I'm just
gonna call it D D for diagonal okay so
what can I say about this diagonal based
on similar triangles
I think D the little diagonal on the V
dial down here right is going to be
equal to
small triangle big triangle small
triangle big triangle you okay with that
that's true similar triangles thankfully
for you you have gotten to a level of
mathematics where you no longer need to
prove the triangles are similar you can
just say that lovely that lovely phrase
that on for you too since love which is
by inspection there you go
because I looked at it and said so now
all right I have this right so what I
actually want is DS isn't it right
that's going to give me that's what I
can put into here to get the UM the area
of the square right so I'm just gonna
rearrange that yes I'll say two on H it
looks like word doesn't it but it's okay
a is a constant thanks H is a constant
height X it has to be very because I'm
going to integrate with respect to that
in a couple of minutes okay okay how do
I go from the length of a diagonal to
the area risk square how do I do it it's
a diagonal don't forget right it's
actually more sideling okay so I can't
just square it if I told you if I told
you he's a um his he's a triangle I saw
I have a square and it's it's diagonal
length for instance with something like
oh I don't know call it call it 10 now
clearly you can work out the area of
this square how would you do it you need
to know side length don't you need to
know assignment so you could do these by
Pythagoras that would work wouldn't it
ah but there's a simpler way there's a
simpler way okay because this is 10
isn't it what's the length of the other
diagonal it's a square so it's 10 can
you see why are you familiar enough with
your quadrilaterals to see that the area
of this guy is 1/2 times the product of
the diagonals can you see it mmm if you
can't see it maybe let me draw in some
lines does that make it any clearer for
those who didn't say yes does that make
it any clearer do you see what I've done
I have made a new red larger
quadrilateral right because I have these
diagonals being perpendicular right
these sides are also perpendicular but
what are the side lengths of this new
shape that I've drawn the red one
it's 10 10 by 10 right but this new one
is exactly twice the size of the shape I
started with okay in fact you can't just
you don't only do this with squares you
do it with anything that has
perpendicular diagonals right
do you remember learning the area of the
kite do you remember the area of a clay
the area of a kite is 1/2 X Y where X Y
are the diagonals do you remember
learning for the area of a rhombus
the area of a rhombus is 1/2 X Y it's
half the product of diodes because the
dye was perpendicular in both cases
anyway now I know I can deal with this
square ok
so if this is the diagonal right then
the area of the square that I'm gonna
put into here will be I'd absolute a bit
of space then I know it's gonna be 1/2
times d squared times the thickness of
the cross section is that okay
hmm you following me so far sound all
right I'm gonna substitute in what D is
cuz because I know what D is okay limit
Delta X approaching 0 from naught to H
of okay
1/2 times a X root 2 on H squared Delta
X okay what's gonna happen here
twos will cancel right twos will cancel
1/2 there there will be a 2 there so
they'll disappear okay what else is
gonna happen here you're gonna get an a
squared and an x squared and an H
squared right tell me which of those are
constants again and H a and H so just
like before wherever I see constants I
just whack them at the front because
they are inconsequential to the actual
integral right okay so I've used this
results I've never rubbed off so my
integral can just keep going okay so
here we go watch what happens I'm taking
these constants out you told me the a
squared and the H squared with both
clusters so how'd they go integral from
naught to H okay the half of the spirit
of 2 squared they've disappeared already
so so what's left in here just just x
squared with respect to X all right
ok so I know how to integrate this
because I just super good at integration
execute 3/4 not to H yeah okay so what
am I getting a squared H squared H cubed
on 3 - 0 H is it gonna cancel so you end
up with a third a squared H or in other
words what you already knew to be the
volume of a pyramid namely a third
time's the area of the base times its
height so let's just review what do we
do we use this thing this guy up here
remember I said the whole market
powerful map
Mattox is its ability to smoothly
transition from one kind of problem to
another okay this line here is so the
same and yet so different from the
previous values but it works like so you
see what we were doing I had to do some
work to get from here to here how did I
do that what mechanism did I use I used
similarity didn't I I had to draw these
guys right diagrams are your friend so I
take that back
good diagrams are your friend okay bad
guy guys not your friends once you did
that and you've got that in terms of the
right variable okay it's mechanical from
there that's all the work is up here and
in yeah